foreign
[Music]
so for my birthday we're going up north
for a week you're gonna come right yeah
it's gonna be fine
yeah it just came up
remember this thing I talked about that
sales thing turns out now they do need
me to go why
just I came up I guess what am I gonna
do without you my beautiful cow
we are so glad that you came happy
birthday happy birthday to you
we just really want you to relax relax
in what way
is everything okay
what's going on
so I think I'm gonna have to leave early
when did he become more important to you
than us
alcohol is burning I lied to him he has
every right to be angry lied about what
about being here
that's my girl
I didn't know you were coming well I'm
sure Alice will explain it all later
are you sorry for what you did how are
we supposed to be happy together if we
can't trust each other
how did Simon know you were here looked
at my email I heard about the girl who
went missing pretty worried about me
my beautiful cow
says what do you think love is I don't
know how any of this is your business
Simon loves me I'm happy
[Music]
why did you lie to him I can't do
another thing wrong
my beautiful girl I'm the only person
who knows
Alice darling
nobody loves you like I love you
my beautiful cow
[Music]